science certainly affects everything we
do, but it's also true that we affect the
scientific process. Imagine that science
and society communicate through a game
of telephone. Information is passed from
hand to hand, or institution to
institution- you see, scientists published
research papers, which eventually reach
policymakers, who then apply the
knowledge in ways that benefit the world.
Right? Well, sort of. This picture gets
complicated once you realize that
society creates a climate of social,
economic, and political factors that
influence scientists and policymakers. The linear game of telephone becomes a
loop, and the scientific message is more
likely to become distorted. Here, we can
show you how this loop is formed by
telling the story of asbestos mining in
South Africa. Wait, wait, wait. You've probably heard of asbestos, but do you really know
what it is?
Asbestos is a mineral that's stronger
than steel, inflammable, sound-absorbent,
and flexible, which makes it an
economically important resource. Between
1910 and 2002, South Africa was the
world's third largest exporter of
asbestos. During that time,
South Africa turned a huge profit, mining
more than 10 million tons of it- that's
equivalent to almost 28 Empire State
Buildings! But let's take a closer look
at the social context. In
twentieth-century South Africa, life was
divided along racial lines of apartheid. The government enforced segregation of
public spaces, medical care, even
citizenship. With limited employment
opportunities, many Black South Africans
turned to manual work like asbestos
mining. Entire families would work
together to drill, collect and separate
asbestos from the earth. But asbestos, as it turns out, is particularly
dangerous to mine. Although asbestos may look like solid rock, when it's drilled
and blasted by miners, it can unravel
into millions of small fibers, which
people can breathe in. Normally, when a
foreign substance enters the lungs, it
gets digested into mucus and coughed up. But asbestos dust built up over time,
eventually causing inflammation
and the formation of scar tissue. Daily
exposure to asbestos may cause serious
respiratory problems that appear later
in life.
Illnesses can lay dormant for decades
within the body, such as mesothelioma,
which are cancerous tumors that
form in vital organs. Families of
mine workers knew they were getting sick
from asbestos exposure, but the industry
ignored their protests. As more people
found out about the dangers of asbestos,
how long do you think it took for mines
to start implementing workplace safety
regulations? In 1959, scientists presented
extensive research demonstrating that
mesothelioma was unusually common
in South African miners, and that even
brief exposure to asbestos could cause
symptoms to appear. It wasn't until 1986
that mining companies started
negotiating with miners to improve
workplace safety-- it took over a quarter
of a century for this science to be
implemented into policy. What happened
here to cause such a delay between
science and action? Well, remember how
society shapes the game of telephone
into a loop? Between 1959 and 1986,
South Africa's economic interests
favored asbestos mining, further
distorting the scientific message. The
1959 publication prompted the mining
industry to fund research on the health
effects of asbestos, but this research
wasn't at all designed to examine the
link between workplace conditions and
lung disease. For example, one study even
attempted to link mesothelioma to a polio
vaccine that most South Africans hadn't
even received. Meanwhile, the mines
continued business as usual while black
laborers protested their unsafe working
conditions. In the mid -70s and
early 80s, the asbestos trade slowed
as both global and domestic economic
pressure against apartheid increased. In
1986, after a national anti-asbestos
campaign and several more strikes, the
first health and safety requirements for
the asbestos mining industry were
finally put into place. In the end, it
took a 'perfect storm' of social, political
and economic factors for science done in
the lab to directly benefit workers in
the mine. Today,
scientific discoveries are made at an
accelerated rate. All of the new
information goes
through a similar game of telephone. The
story of asbestos mining shows us that
while society depends on informed
science, scientists also need reminding
of social contexts.
A study in 2008, for example, showed that
carbon nanotubes have a fiber shape
similar to asbestos. When mice were
exposed to these nanotubes, they
developed mesothelioma-like
symptoms. Billions of dollars are funding
nanotechnology research, and carbon
nanotubes can already be found in a
variety of products for sunscreen to
eyeglasses. In short, scientists have
introduced promising material, but
ongoing research points to potentially
harmful effects of its use. Sound
familiar?
Science is a series of social
interactions, and especially when it
comes to health,
any conflicting messages in the
conversation can have serious
consequences. People such as science
writers, professors and citizen
scientists work against the likelihood
of these miscommunications! Moving
forward, it is important to shorten the
gap between scientists and the public, to
fortify the imperfect loop and keep
scientific messages connected to their
social contexts!